northwest has some words of wisdom for
her cousin true thompson who had the
perfect fourth birthday party get it
because it was cat themed i think it
works khloe kardashian threw her
daughter the cutest b-day bash over the
weekend complete with real kittens for
the party-goers to play with it's just a
ball
while true doesn't officially turn four
until tuesday coco and the rest of the
karjenner fam got together on sunday to
shower the toddler with lots of love and
plenty of party games
[Music]
the birthday girl wore a pink feathered
dress and pink braided hair extensions
to the soiree which featured colorful
pastel balloons face paint a pink
inflatable slide a three-tiered cat and
rainbow-themed cake and true's very own
personalized m ms in pink purple and
blue she's gonna freak out she loves m
m's and yes
have your face on it
yes they did have true's face on them i
know
oh but that's not all there were squish
mallow party favors and a squishmallow
cat performer too
[Music]
literally the party of every
four-year-old's dreams
genuinely i cannot believe it so who
attended the celebration true's cousins
five-year-old dream nine-year-old
penelope eight-year-old north
four-year-old chicago and four-year-old
stormy girls are here
dreamy and shy shy and truthful
[Music]
as well of a bunch of other pals and
true's aunts kylie jenner and kim
kardashian and north threw down some
hilarious subtle shade about being four
years old in this message to her cousins
let's see that one more time because
north she knows what's up
true celebration comes just days after
chloe brought her little girl to the red
carpet premiere of the family's new hulu
reality series the kardashians
over the last year
we've seen such transformations from all
of us
this is day one oh my god are you dying
are you dying
the 37 year old's good american founder
shared snaps from the night on instagram
in the caption she wrote that she was so
excited for the april 14th release date
there's way more pressure but it's
exciting meanwhile e.t recently sat down
with the famous fam to talk about the
show and chloe says she plans to bear it
all
at least for now is there anything you
won't show or are there no boundaries i
think for every sister we have different
boundary levels and we all try to
respect that your boundaries are allowed
to change and mine will probably change
later but
i'm also i think a lot of us are you
know what is in the media is sort of
things that we feel we need to film
because it's in a way unfair to the
viewers if they don't get to see that
we've shared so much about our lives
especially the older ones we've been
doing this for so long they started as
babies so i guess we didn't expect them
to share as much and they have a right
to set up their boundaries so i think
moving forward things might change with
me but who knows i am an open book and i
like to be that way
[Music]
you